good morning everyone it's an
extraordinarily momentous occasion today
as we begin one of the most important
and inspiring chapters in the history of
Carnegie Mellon University
the Tepper quad will embody distinctive
academic vision of Carnegie Mellon how
different disciplines come together in
new and unique ways it'll be the
physical symbol of what will evolve as a
Anchor Point of the new innovation
corridor it'll become the geographic
epicenter of the University as the
university grows in ways that we foresee
now and in ways we don't foresee at this
point in time we can't wait to see our
programs move into this incredible space
a space that will truly reflect the
innovative education that takes place at
both the Tempur school and across the
Carnegie Mellon campus this is the
promise for a better future for our
community as represented by the Tempur
quad before david gives his remarks i
would like to invite two students to
join me on stage as we present a gift
for this enormous generosity the
Carnegie Mellon University you know
today it's a you know it's a really
great day and it's it's a combination of
a vision that Suber and I shared not
just a new building or a quad but a
vision of Education and that vision of
Education of on the college and graduate
school level is trying to bring all the
schools and interact them there's really
no formal formal ways that we do it it's
done here they're another this quad you
heard super talking about a little bit
this is Carnegie Mellon just not talking
to talk we're gonna walk the walk
you